foreign
[Music]
how's it going partying what are you
doing
I'm actually just sitting looking at the
ocean coming like a very amazing view
place right now
sir thanks for kicking us while we're
down appreciate that Joe real cool I
hope you have a 40 below winter in
Canada
uh I'm really overnight out but so
what's up
um well first of all thanks for having
me on your show I appreciate it
absolutely thanks for calling in
and secondly I need your help on how I
deal with like conflict and I'll give
you a little background but that's kind
of the basis of it okay
um
so when I grew up my mom just recently
has been diagnosed kind of with
borderline personality disorder disorder
okay so I kind of diagnosed or all the
way
diagnosed
um all the way diagnosed okay but it's
just very recent so it's still like in
process
um but so as a kid I kind of got a lot
of that the like brunt of
all of that and so I became a people
pleaser and just like terrified of
conflict since
I've kind of learned how to deal with it
with her but that also took almost
completely detaching myself emotionally
from her
um but then hang on one second for those
listening being the child of somebody
with borderline personality disorder is
uh frog's hair away of torture because
emotions are blow torches both the good
ones and the bad ones right
yeah and it is something that a
child cannot understand why mom is so
out of her mind angry over this and then
suddenly
she's laughing hysterically about a joke
that's not that funny and suddenly now
we're hugging and dancing and now we're
back to screaming like it is
trying to find equilibrium as a child is
it just it's everything's in chaos am I
onto it right Joe
yes yes okay
so yes often the only way a child can
survive that is to completely unplug
which is why you've got kids who are in
substance abuse or and really intense
romantic relationships very very early
um because they've got to detach from
the original power source here because
the power source is too unstable
Okay so
wow that sounds like my childhood yes
I feel like she hid it from me until I
was like a teen so it wasn't like
necessarily my childhood but yeah
definitely my like you know from 12 on
okay yeah
um but yeah so then fast forward to
about 20
17 2018.
um
my I
okay my husband is diagnosed with cancer
probably like
2016. oh man and it was never gonna be
like a
they never thought it was a
life-threatening one but anyway turns
out two years later they were very wrong
and
[Music]
uh we at this time were living with my
in-laws which is not a great place to be
when you're going through hard times if
that relationship's already not you know
perfect
um and
my
way of dealing with with it was very
different and I am odd way of dealing
with it
um which led to a lot of conflict and
at one point they asked me if I even
like cared about like him basically and
this is well I have two little girls and
so I was trying to live like a somewhat
normal life for them like I know nothing
was going to be normal but anyway this
was because I was going out for brunch
with my family as opposed to watching
hours of video on the treatment they
wanted to do which I was there before my
husband I was like whatever he wants to
do oh Jojo I don't have the energy oh
sorry don't ever ever feel like you have
to defend that ever I know okay nonsense
Madness
um
but yeah so
so you know it wasn't because of that
day that day may have been the straw
that broke the camel's back but you lost
your mind because you had a really rough
childhood and then the man of your the
the guy you hit your wagon to next died
on you right
yeah yeah yes so he didn't die at this
point he was just in like very terminal
State at this time he was he was he was
dying on you right he was dying yeah
um but yeah so
there was just many times in like a six
week stand that things got super tense
between us and then after he actually
passed my in-laws
there was just like tension and it was
never really a dress it was just kind of
oh enough time standby let's hopefully
everyone just forgot about it and move
on and now you're holding the key to
their magic little grandkids
exactly and those little grandkids are
there they have put all of their missing
love from their son into those little
two little girls to prop them up
yeah
and so I am just trying to understand
a I've moved away about a few months ago
just for a year for like I moved up to
uh please I'm from a different province
in Alberta and so I moved out to a place
that I could actually like rest for a
little bit and they came and visited
without giving me much
options as to say no that they couldn't
come at a certain weekend and it just
brought up so much anxiety and stress
for me that I honestly didn't think was
there okay and so I just it like brought
everything back of
how
it hurt I was and how I just feel like
everything's just to be forgotten and
even with how they showed up there was
never like an apology of like oh I'm
sorry we didn't take your schedule into
consideration it was just like now oh
well this is when it works in in their
defense
do they know this stuff
um what stuff
um I all I always give people a ton of
Grace
as they're dealing with the death of a
loved one
because everybody does that differently
and the old saying goes nobody makes
good decisions when they're scared or
when they're drunk
and there's a few things more terrifying
so
I absolutely think the way they treated
you from what you've just told me was
abhorrent and awful
and as bad as it was I want to flip the
other side of the coin and look at two
people who are losing their son they're
losing everything they've got
and the dog the father of these two
little girls that they love
and they start laughing their choice of
how to cope was to lash out okay now I'm
not saying you have to be in a
relationship with him in fact it sounds
like that's not a good idea
but I want to know if you have given
them notice
as to how you feel because if you don't
and by the way you giving notice to how
you feel
would have got your 14 year old self's
head knocked off
so your body knows do not tell people
how you feel you shut up you be quiet
about it and let them go about their day
because that's the safest way forward
except you can't keep going forward like
that anymore not with your two little
girls Fair yeah
totally fair so they have a right to
know
I think
go ahead
um I feel like I have
said
things like I've actually been said like
well we don't really need a relationship
between us like but I will never keep my
kids away from you like you'll always be
their grandparents and they're like but
we love you we want you to be in our
lives
and so
hey that's the part that's hard is
because I do know that they in their own
way love me and so I don't want to like
you know crush them but also I don't
know how to have a relationship with
them
because of how
things have gone in the past and just
how they are
as individuals they don't necessarily
take
other people being strong-willed very
well
and I
am just I really want to honor them and
their relationship with their
grandchildren and who they are ah no you
don't no you don't you want to avoid
conflict you want to avoid a fight I do
you don't want to honor them you want
them to be able to see their grandkids
and have no issues
they've created issues
and you've got issues the deal is can we
have our issues together
yeah so at some point like an offhanded
well like we're like we don't have to
have a relationship but I'll never keep
the girls from you
like out of left field a little bit
that's kind of like I don't know it's
not grenade throwing it's like throwing
a rock at a tank like did somebody just
throw a rock at us that's kind of like
that and then you went back and told
your friends I I'm leaving I went after
that tank like I mean kind of right so
foreign
here's the thing
you want to not hurt anybody's feelings
you want to not get in a fight
you also are tired of being controlled
by other people
you're tired of not being able to move
on and live your life
and you're tired of having your feelings
not count
and you can't pick
you can't have it all you gotta choose
and for your sake and for the sake of
those two little girls that are watching
their mom for how to deal with the worst
possible thing that could happen
for watching their two little girls
watching their mom
teach them about
your needs deserve to be heard you have
a right to say them out loud and here's
how you do that with dignity and respect
and boundaries are critical
all three of you deserve
to not live under the perceived tyranny
of a moment a grandma and a Granddad
that's just going to show up at your
house in some random Wednesday and stay
for a week
or that if you haven't had the
conversation yet about how you treated
me while my husband was dying
um and you all haven't worked through
that then man like you deserve more than
that
and here's so here's how I would do it I
don't like conflict either I don't love
it I don't run from it and I'll have it
I don't love it
um I think the first step always is to
write things down
yeah here's what you actually did and
said and here's what I felt
and if you can mail that in a
handwritten letter not an email bomb but
a handwritten letter
or if you say hey I've been thinking
about what this is going to look like
long term and long term who knows right
you might get remarried you might move
to the States you might move to Ireland
who knows
so we're going to do this a year at a
time
but for the next year here's what I need
or here not even so much what I need
here's what we're gonna do
you can see the girls on this date and
on this date
it's going to be great you all are free
to move your schedules around but this
is when this is going to happen
and
um
because we are healing as a family we're
not going to have any surprise show UPS
and expect them to try you on it
them just show up hey they're welcome
too you're not staying here and let me
tell you something if you lay out it out
clear not little passing rocks thrown at
a tank if you lay it out clear
in
Christmas
we're gonna come see you guys for three
days
and we're going to stay at a hotel and
the girls can spend the night at your
house once or twice
and we're gonna see you on spring break
those are the two times over the course
of the next year
um if you lay it out that clearly and
they show up and you don't let them stay
we drove seven hours well you drove
seven hours I'm sorry but we're heading
out to an event right now
you will you will walk six inches taller
okay so I'm going to give you the line
I've used it before on this show I don't
even remember where I got it from maybe
brene brown maybe Esther perel I want
you to always As you move forward choose
guilt over resentment
okay
I want you to say no and feel really
guilty about saying no then have them
show up to your house unannounced or
with two days notice which is a total
power move
or you got to see who they what they
really think about you and the chips
were down
and now they're being all sweet and nice
to you because you are the pathway to
those grandkids and they're playing a
long game until those girls turn 18 and
they then they're going to swoop in and
save the day and blah blah blah blah
blah no way no way
we're going to choose guilt I'm gonna
say no no thank you oh I see I drove
seven hours to show up here and it's the
middle of winter it's negative a million
degrees here in uh
Canada sorry
but tonight's not a good night
um I told you I remember when I told you
very specifically when we were gonna
have people here
um now's not that time and you're going
to feel guilty as bloody hell you'll
feel so guilty but if you let them come
stay and they come again the next time
and they come again the next time
and then when they're 16 they're going
to send you a car for the girls even
though you've got a very clear financial
plan for them and I think there's just
going to be a power move after power
you're going to resent yourself
you're gonna start to resent those
little girls and you're especially going
to resent them
don't do that don't choose resentment
choose relationship and choose guilt
choose boundaries
okay
this is a skill you have to practice
because boundaries got you hurt as a kid
and you had really strong boundaries
around that man you loved and he died
and so your body has equated boundaries
with no no no no no no no no
so you're gonna have to practice I'd get
a friend that you trust and you love and
you'll sit down and do boundaries
together help you write the letter
together
exhale
send that letter
make the phone call make the visit and
say hey these are my girls this is my
life and this is how we're going to do
this moving forward
and they get to choose to be adults
and opt into your world because that's
really the only choice they've got
I'm proud of you Joe